Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conners and in this presentation, we're talking about
cancer cures and here we're going to be talking about rife technology.
Five ways rife technology changes the way that we treat cancer today and it should be
changing the way everybody treats cancer.
That's my opinion of course, but we've seen miracles after miracles using the rife and we just
want to show it from the mountain tops.
People that are not using the rife are missing a big piece of what could help them get better.
It is not a miracle cure.
It doesn't cure everybody and you have to have your body ability to heal has to be there.
The biggest mistake that people make with the rife when they use the right frequencies
and they're using the right equipment is that they wait too long.
But that being said, we've seen stage 4 cancer patients that were literally given 2 weeks
to live.
By Mayo Clinic, we practice a Minnesota so we have a lot of Mayo patients and said home
to get their fares in order, live several years more and die from other causes.
So it has been just a miracle cure.
You could say even though we're using the word cancer, cures, I don't believe anything, cures
cancer.
It's been a miracle cure in the sense that it's given people their life back and allowed
them to manage their cancer for a lot longer than was ever expected and it's just been a
blessing.
So we're going to go down these 5, 4, 3, 2, 1, how I understand there's at least 2 different
technical understandings and philosophies and why rife light frequency works.
We're just going to hit 5 here that I think are easier to understand.
Number 1 or number 5, I should say rife light frequencies vibrate the cells that they're
targeting.
If you hit anything with its own frequency, you cause it to vibrate.
And that is important when you're dealing with cancer cells.
What are the things that cancer cells do to evade, getting killed by your immune system is
that because they're rapidly replicating, they're creating a lot of waste and that waste in
itself is acidic.
So you may have heard that cancer doesn't grow in an alkaline environment and it's because
you're acidic that causes cancer to grow.
Well, if you've read any of my information or seen any of my other videos, I don't believe
that that's exactly true.
Though acidic tissue can cause problems, it is really the rapid replication of the cells
causing so much waste that is producing acidity and cancer in itself is producing an acidic
environment.
Now that acidic environment collects around this rapid, rapidly growing cell mass and
that in itself physically keeps away an immune attack, prevents an immune attack on the rapidly
growing cell mass, the cancer itself.
So heating it with its own frequency physically causes that to break up and physically helps
the live system carry that away and physically will allow the immune system to help attack it.
So in itself, using RIF technology can help your immune system kill the cancer.
This presupposes that you're doing some things that will stimulate an immune response and
build an immune response if you're in the middle of doing chemo and radiation where your
immune response is so diminished already, you need some support with that as well.
So this fifth piece is not going to have as much effect if your immune system is diminished
or if you're in the stages of death that your immune system is shut down.
It's very important to do things to increase the health of the immune system as well.
There were four RIF light frequencies help bring residents back to the cells that are targeted.
From a quantum physics perspective, everything has its own residents, has its own resident
frequency.
And part of the problem with cancer is that it's resonated in a different frequency that
it should have been.
So if you hit any tissue with its old residents, this is the argument that people will make.
Well, if right flight kills cancer cells, wouldn't it kill your liver cells too?
Wouldn't it kill your healthy cells?
How can it only kill the bad cells, quote, unquote, not kill healthy cells?
Well, when you're hitting it with its own frequency, you're bringing residents back to that
tissue.
You're not necessarily trying to kill the cancer.
You're trying to bring the residents back to those cells.
So the cancer cells don't act like cancer cells anymore, and we're going to talk a little bit
more about that in these steps.
But remember what cancer is.
Cancer isn't some crazy different cell that's not normally in the body that's not taking over
your body.
Cancer is your old tissue cell.
So if I have liver cancer, it is a liver cell that instead of going through its natural
apoptosis cycle, meaning going through a life cycle, doing its job, and then going through
a death cycle called apoptosis where the cell compoded, so recycled back by the body of the
cell dies.
The cell doesn't go through apoptosis for a specific reason.
We talk about that in multiple different slide presentations on our website, so check that
out.
And then it goes into a rapid replication cycle, and there's a reason for that too.
Finding the cause of that is a huge piece of what we want to look at.
So by definition, a cancer cell is in a state of rapid replication.
If we can bring normal residents back to that cell, you can help from a quite a physics standpoint
stop it from being a cancer cell.
So not just the cancer itself, but dealing with the rest of the liver.
So if I have liver cancer, if I could get my liver back to normal harmonic residents,
I'm going to be able to help detox and do everything that the liver is supposed to do.
If I could get my immune system back to normal residents, I'm going to help stimulate it
in the immune response.
If I could get my thyroid, any tissue cell we're talking about, if you hit it with its own
frequency, you're going to bring normal residents back to that tissue.
You're going to help with bringing the normal quantum physics frequency back to that tissue.
That's a huge piece of what RIF does.
Number three, RIF light frequencies alkalize the tissue that it's targeted.
So if we're targeting, if we're doing a liver frequencies at a percentage, you're using
it.
And that's what's coming, those light frequencies are coming through the RIF ball, then you
are going to alkalize the liver because you're targeting those liver cells and light
bead a waveform that is also a photon on a waveform, acts as an electrode dotator.
So it dotates an electron to the tissue and when you dotate an electron to the tissue,
you are raising the pH of the tissue.
So some people argue that this is the biggest way that RIF technology actually helps people
with cancer and other diseases is you're just, you're alkalizing the tissue.
And as we stated before, cancer is acidic in its own realm because of its rapid replication
and producing so much waste.
So alkalizing the tissue is very important.
Number two, RIF light frequencies can stop cancer cells from being cancer cells.
We talked about it the fourth one.
If we can bring resonance back to those cells, you can induce an apoptonic cycle.
You can stop in this case, stop a rapid replication cycle.
So if we could stop it from rapidly replicating, then it may still be there but it's not rapidly
replicating anymore.
And we see this very common with patients that the mass is still there but it's stopped growing.
So is that good?
Is that bad?
That's humongous.
So do we care that the cancer goes away?
No, we just want those cells to stop being cancer cells.
And when I say stop being cancer cells, I mean stop rapidly replicating.
We don't care if they all disappear.
We just care that they stop replicating.
They're no longer acting as cancer cells if they're not in rapid replication anymore.
We'll just let them stay there and let the body wall it off.
That's just fine by us.
And number one, RIF light frequencies can kill cancer cells.
So not only can they stop rapid replication, therefore they're not cancer cells, quote unquote
anymore, they can cause apoptosis to take place.
And this is what RIF actually found with his microscope.
He saw that there was actually a lysis.
So there was actually a necrosis of the cancer tissue using light frequency.
And we do see this at different times where a person comes in and their cancer, they go
back and do another MRI or CT and their cancer is greatly reduced in size or God.
And that seems to be kind of what patients in their mind want because that tells you that
the cancer is God.
However, we got to be careful because just because you can't see an MRI or CT scan
doesn't mean it's completely God and my belief again, it's never cured it.
It's never completely God and you need to just learn to manage it the rest of your life.
And you see the RIF as a key component of that.
However, it does not always happen that way.
So again, that's not always even what we're trying to do.
We don't want it to disappear or we just want it to stop being a cancer cell and stop replicating.
So hopefully this helps you understand we use RIF in our office.
All our cancer patients go home with a RIF machine and it's an essential part of our treatment
using the right frequencies, you see the right machine, you see the right amount of time.
Other frequencies is essential.
That's exactly what we do in programming it, but it's not all that we do.
You have to, like I said earlier, stimulate an immune response.
You could use nutraceuticals to help kill the cancer, you got to look at different metabolic
pathways that may be blocking different things, it's a complex thing.
I don't want to try to make it sound simple, but if you could get to the source of the cause
and be able to halt it from being cancer, it's, you could see miracles and the RIF is certainly
a piece of this.
Make sure you check out the other videos on our website, it's up there in the left-hand
corner or call our office if you have any questions, thanks and God bless.